تفاعل واسع خلفه سجال بين الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون ورئيس الكونغو
الديمقراطيه فليكس الذي خيم على اختتام
زياره الرئيس الفرنسي الافريقيه ففي مؤتمر
صحفي عقد في كنشاسا ساده توتر بين
الرئيسين عندما طلب الرئيس الكونغولي من
الرئيس ماكرون ان تتخلى فرنسا عن المنطق
الابوي في تعاملها مع الدول الافريقيه
يقال انه على المسؤولين الفرنسيين التعامل
مع الكونغو كشريك وليس عبر الاملاءات هذا
السجال كان بعد سؤال من صحفيه فرنسيه
للرئيس الكونغولي عن ظروف اجراء
الانتخابات في الدول الافريقيه مستخدمه
عباره وزير الخارجيه الفرنسيه السابق الذي
وصفها بتوافقات افريقيه
عندما تكون هناك مخالفات في الانتخابات
الامريكيه لا نقول توافقات على الطريقه
الامريكيه وعندما كانت فضيحه في فرنسا على
عهد الشراك قبل سنوات وسجدت اصوات باسماء
موتى لم نتحدث عن توافقات على الطريقه
الفرنسيه اعتقد انه يجب ان يسود الاحترام
في نظرتنا لبعضنا البعض يجب ان يحدث تغيير
في تعاوننا مع فرنسا واوروبا انظروا الينا
بطريقه مختلفه فيها احترام لنا واعتبرونا
شركاء حقيقيين لا تنظر الينا دائما نظره
ابويه مع فكره انكم تعرفون دائما ما يصلح
لنا
رغم التصفيق اذا سمح لي الرئيس تشيلسي
كيدي اريد ان اضيف تعليقا الى التعليق
عندما يطرح صحفي او صحفيه فرنسيه سؤالا
فهذا لا يعني الحكومه الفرنسيه لا هذا ليس
موقف فرنسا
انا اشير الى تصريحاتي هو يعبر عن الموقف
الرسمي الفرنسي عباره التوافقات على
الطريقه الافريقيه تعود وليس للصحفيه
هذا صحيح هذه العباره نعرف من اين خرجت
ونعرف الاطار الانتخابيه الذي استخدمت فيه
لم يكن ايزدراء في عباره
الاكاديمي المتخصص في الشؤون الافريقيه في
جامعه فالنسيان الفرنسيه اهلا بك سيد صديق
يعني كيف تعلقون على هذا
السيجال
وعن ماذا تكشف تصريحات الرئيس الكونغولي
برايك
نعم رئيس جمهوريه الكونغو قال ما يعتقده
وهو يؤمن به هي الكثير من الفريق ينبغي
اعتبار افريقيا كشريك على بقيه الشركاء
ولا ينبغي ان تختار قوى اخرى ما يناسب
الفرقه اعتقد انما قاله رئيس الكونغوليلي
نظيره الفرنسي هو انه ضروره هناك ضروره
للتعامل مع الفريق الراشدين يعرفون ما
يريدون وما يطمحون اليه والافا يعرفونه
يصلح لهم وما لا يصلح بالتالي في الماضي
في السابق كان هناك الكثير من التنقيص من
قيمه يحدث ما الذي حدث لان تتغير هذه
النظره او لان يدعوا الافارقه والرئيس
الكونغولي من خلال هذه التصريحات لاتتغير
هذه النظره الابويه او الفوقيه من قبل
فرنسا
تغيرت هناك الان مجموعه من الشركاء
الاخرين الذين يطرقون ابواب افريقيا
لنتحدث فقط عن روسيا لكن هناك الصين تركيا
وشركاء اخرين موجودين على الارض الافريقيه
ويمكن
لافريقيا ان تيمم وجه شطرهم اذا امتنعت
اوروبا ان تتعامل وان تصنع شركات حقيقيه
مع الافارقه في افريقيا لديها خيرات اخرى
راينا افريقيا الوسطى تتوجه نحو روسيا
مالي ايضا
تتجه نحو روسيا بوركينا فاسو الذي طلبت من
فرنسا سحب قواتها وبالتالي اليوم لدينا
افريقيا مختلفه عن افريقيا
السابقه وهي كانت تحت السيطره الاوروبيه
والفرنسيه وهذه هي الفرصه الجديده تعطي
فرصه لافريقيا
لاختيار اذا تكون فرنسا تسعى لنخراط في
شراكه حقيقيه تشكل مصدر الربح لكافه
الاطراف في افريقيا لديهم امكانيه اخرى
ايضا على المستوى الداخلي الشباب الافريقي
غير مستعد للقبول بمقابل به ابائهم
واجدادهم الان الشباب الافريقي مرتبط
بالفيسبوك بتويتر بوصيله التواصل التواصل
الاجتماعي
واذا ما جمعنا كل هذه العوامل التي تؤدي
للتغيير فنحن نرى بان هناك هذا التغيير
الذي نتحدث بشانه وافريقيا لا تقبل
العلاقات القديمه التي اكلت دهر عليها
وشرب